[Music]
welcome to air biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc this week get the roundtable of
dim lighting we have another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet we're bringing to you
this time Matthew Santoro now I'm sure
you've seen his videos at least a
handful of them list videos designed to
satisfy inquisitive minds each week just
look for a new thumbnail of a bald
bearded dude with the Cheshire Cat smile
and millions of views registering
underneath it and you will have found
Matthew Santoro
do that week and now usually these
videos come in the form of a top 10 list
that is what he is very well known for
now with quote mind-blowing in quote
facts and trivia irresistible clickable
titles like and I'm gonna use my
irresistible clickable voice 10 most
fascinating things ever found in space
10 most haunted places on earth go
deeper said incredible animals with
real-life superpowers 10 freakiest
coincidences in history and for this
last one can you go like monster truck
announcer I spy spit a little bit you
wish you could have seen it
alright here's a clip from one of Matt's
more recent in popular videos over five
and a half million views titled toon
cannot should you say this into I mean I
could go to next level monster truck guy
okay do it catch that it was 10 creepy
urban legends that turned out to be true
number 6 is creatures in your toilet
this one will pucker you but ho this
urban legend is about a man that gets
out of bed half asleep in the middle of
the night and walks to the washroom to
do his business only to get bit by a
giant rat right in the bath now even
though matt has been making videos since
2010 his success is really recent and
it's kind of mind-boggling how quickly
he has ascended up the ranks in a
three-month time span from May through
July of this year
he doubled his subscriber base skyrocket
him from 1 million to 2 million
subscribers just in those 3 months and
he's still growing right as of this
recording he's got over two and a half
million subscribers so the dude is just
it's an interesting case study yeah and
someone who can refine something and
it's like it caught fire it's it's
interesting right so we're talking him
talking to him in the midst of this
incredible upswing that he has been
experiencing this year so let's kind of
let's call this a case study ear biscuit
I mean we discuss lots of things
his famous teeth his previous life as a
professional accountant and we get into
unpacking the secrets to this incredibly
quick rise to fame on YouTube and in the
approach of navigating this competitive
world of internet list videos here it is
that your biscuit with Matthew Santoro
[Music]
now I gotta admit I was hoping that when
we offered you coffee you would say yes
and then you would request a straw ah
because we know that this is a thing you
drink on your straw
ah so you did your research hello that
we always research who do you think yes
I do what give us the backstory on
drinking coffee through a straw I have
my theories there's actually no real
backstory it's just just general
maintenance for the old chompers that's
all it is so you know it gots to keep
them white as white as possible and
drinking I you know anytime I have it
makes a little difficult when you're at
a dinner or a party trying to be classy
and you're drinking red wine through a
straw looks a little odd but oh so you
you're all way you never miss I totally
commit I've never been on a date and
done that but what I do is like anytime
I'm going out
I choose white wine over red on purpose
regardless of the dish Wow yes I'm
committed I gotta say that I do feel
like your teeth are a big part of your
brand they are and it's funny because
people are always like why do you show
so much teeth and it is it's just the
it's the smile thing I know it sounds
stupid but no but I don't think it's
just a smile
I feel like if I was designing a human
for like some sort of and I was like
okay I gotta use this person's eyes I
gotta use this person's elbows first of
all I wouldn't use my elbows because
they're very pointy unless this was like
a fighter because I cannot blow somebody
in the face but I would choose your
teeth oh wow
you know they they're they're very large
I feel like you have very large you
could you could bite something like like
they're they're very white they're very
straight they're very prominent I'm not
in like a we're not talking like a horse
mouth situation we're just talking like
Bionic the nice dude bionic man like oh
I got to put Matt Santoro's teeth on
this robot yeah you know what I mean
this robot we're we're designing to
overtake the human race Matt what make
you feel a little better before you
respond what's behind this for Rhett is
he's jealous because if you've if you
look at him now or any videos that you
can't see the guy's teeth yeah like he
try as hard as he made a show people his
TV can't do it but there are people who
are convinced he doesn't even have teeth
right yeah and I'm one of those but I
got small teeth I got a small small
mouth I mean you're a giant man I am
well yeah exit extra awkward yeah so
those things may have seemed like a cut
on you but basically it's just revealing
one of his deepest insecurities is that
people think he's to compliment it is
freaking teeth man right I got robots
large teeth is a good thing and it's not
a it's not a bad thing it's not like I
see a bunch of gums over there it's not
a gummy smile one of those smiles I mean
they're man smiles and all you see is
big bright white teeth this is a
compliment I would protect him - yeah
ma'am just regular regular - like did
you have braces I have never had braces
really yep never it'll work done no no
work done fillings I've had fillings but
that's about it I mean no nothing
nothing special done it's just
maintenance my man but but you're very
committed to the whiteness of your teeth
the whiteness yes I'm very very much so
I I mean all you got to do is just
maintain them so I use a lot of
Listerine anti stainless tureen not a
sponsor I have but I use that I use a
you know whitening toothpastes just just
regular matron but what is what would
happen what would happen if the teeth
faded to yellow oh you'd lose well I was
just everyone would unsubscribe and I'd
be on the street I mean that's that's
all it is
I mean they they're I guess but what I'm
saying is there are quite in focus like
for me I don't worry about my teeth at
all cuz he's like link said you never
see him yeah you know I mean I think
they're relatively white and relatively
straight but they're not that white and
that straight
but they don't have to be yeah but when
you when you are the bionic man such as
yourself right on ik mouth
they gotta be straight they gotta be
white and they are have you ever had
like your bite strength tested no no I
well my father was a shark and and my
mother was just a bucket of white paint
so that's why you know I am Who I am
that's weird
yeah it is weird I don't even know how
they got together how does the shark
another episode I can't even still
trying to figure that out
okay so too bad we didn't get to see it
in action though but there is water you
can just drink I will not stain your
teeth yeah perfect preciate American
water yeah but you got to watch it when
drinking like a hot beverage through a
straw like coffee man you could you get
your sinning you know it's the Melbourne
o'clock rest to the back of yo me out
there well I thought it one thing I
think about is you know I I I use a new
straw every day of course but drinking
hot coffee if I'm straw yeah well like a
like a disposable straw every day
because I have coffee every morning well
you could get like a metal straw oh yeah
that's the thing yeah they say eco straw
you get a woods wooden straw too I think
you just changed my life yeah get some
wooden straw bamboo straw okay well I'm
gonna have to definitely look into that
because I've been using plastic straws
and for a while now we've been thinking
over the course of a year let's say
hypothetically I drink 365 cups of
coffee
one straw per coffee how much of the
straw is getting melted while I'm
drinking and how much plot so have I
consumed a couple straws over the course
of a year so what are the with the
impact of that is making this up because
I just said wooden straw because I
figured it yep it exists you can buy
them in a five pack
handcrafted wood straw 5-pack $17 at sea
reusable yes if they're not that
interior designs on them really holy
mackerel yeah you need it you know what
hey this is a sponsor right when I get
back to Canada that's first thing I'm
bars first we're gonna send you a pack
that's our that's our thank you I'm
making this biscuit I just made my day
man thank you so much like a would
straws all right so let's get let's go a
little deeper than the teeth and I'm
good stay here what he thinks about la I
have you been to LA before yes I love LA
I love California in general it's just
it's beautiful it's always sunny the
people are beautiful you know you guys
are here what more could you want but I
mean it's no Canada it's that's right I
mean there are positives and negatives
like MOG yeah oh there's smog here mmm
yeah we don't get a lot we don't get a
lot of that in Canada stain your teeth
no let's ma get through a straw for now
oh that's what I'm yeah that's right um
no I mean I love I love living in Canada
I live right near I live in a town
called st. Catherine's which is about 30
minutes away from Niagara Falls and
Niagara Falls is the type of thing where
you ever been over uh no I had
definitely have not but there have been
multiple people that have tried some
survived some haven't oh yeah it's quite
illegal but you're gonna show on that
yet uh no I've done I don't know I've
done the top ten on pretty much
everything now but try think I've done
one on that what we've done that but you
can still do it actually I just did one
on ten inventors killed by their own
inventions and one of them was a guy
that invented what he called the capsule
and he used this thing to go over the
falls and he survived so you do you know
about this guy he was years later was
something related right yes so so the
first time he did it everything was fine
so these guys I believe he was in Dallas
Texas the Houston Astrodome I think it
was and they created an artificial
waterfall over something along those
lines and he went over in the capsule
except the Houston Astrodome was
apparently much higher and what happened
was he
something like that and he fell when he
impacted he hit the side of the pool
anyways the capsule exploded he died and
that was the end of that but he didn't
hit in actually like on target so that's
why he died so he was like doing a test
he's doing a ticket selling
demonstration like he was a he was a
celebrity it's like come seed ready to
win over the Falls go over the fake
Falls here right and he'll die you gotta
stick to the real Falls when you want to
yeah exactly
well you know that topic is a good
example of something that it takes
thought and calculation to come up with
a good subject for a good list video and
you've you've you've got it down to
you've honed it to an R you know but my
question is there's such a wide range of
topics um of serial killers from to
sports it's a science to science fiction
how do you decide what to do an episode
on inventors who've you know who were
killed by their own inventions you know
where do these things come from well I
actually have two sources one is real
life so I'll just be living my life I
don't know walk into a store and
something will click and I'll just say
oh that's a good idea I'll put it down
on my phone the other one which is
usually my biggest source is sometimes
it's all the internet obviously so I'll
either Google just a random topic or I
will use one of the I have a I have a
folder in chrome where I have and this
is I've never told anyone this so this
isn't for you guys but I have a folder
in chrome where I have about 10 or more
list websites and you guys know there's
tons of these list lists websites and
what I'll do is I'll search randomly
through their lists and then I'll find
one so for example I'll find a you know
6 the 6 creepiest foods or grossest
foods on earth and then that'll be like
ok that's a great topic so what I'll do
is I'll use that idea and google it and
use you know I'll cherry pick from the
10 websites that pop up and cherry-pick
the best ones and then do further
research on those so I never just use
one website because you'd be surprised
at how much false information there is
especially when you're doing like my
series 50 amazing facts a lot of these
facts quote unquote websites that are
out there
you know especially the ones that people
share on Facebook and things like that a
lot of them I'd say 50% of them are
false yeah of the ones that you read
online once you actually look into it
they're either completely false or just
unfounded like and they've been
replicated on multiple websites
sometimes yeah yeah it's the type of
thing where you know a false fact B
almost becomes truth because everybody
starts saying it like even when you you
know one of these websites will misquote
somebody or something and you know then
BuzzFeed will pick it up and then
cracked I'll pick it and they just all
pick it up and so it but it's but it's
false so in in the first couple 50
amazing facts that I made I actually
accidentally used a couple of those and
ever since then people called me out on
I thought oh I'll call you out oh they
definitely well I mean especially with a
big audience they people yeah there's
always one and that's it so ever since
then I've been really really diligent
about researching these things and you
know if I can't find absolute guaranteed
something that I'm certain about I just
leave the fact out now well interesting
we can say you know with good mythical
morning we basically apply the same
system in terms of when we do a list
episode right which I want to get into
that I want to get into this the
dynamics of that and how we and you feel
about that that approach but as you say
that I mean that's definitely our
approach our approach is let's not just
go to one website because a we don't
want to just do the same list that
somebody else did because then it's just
we're just biting off for them so but if
there's what there's a list on the
internet it's been done 10 times of
course and so yeah everything's are
remixed remind your favorites and then
cut in offer commentary yeah yeah but
we'll get into the mechanics of that
that later but we want to we want to
find out about the the Matt that became
the Matt Santoro of today so let's go
back I'm assuming the origins are in
Canada yes yes do you want me just begin
yeah where did you come from
well my mother well my mother but um
essentially I grew up in a small town
again this is something I haven't told
anyone before so but I grew up in a
small town called well in Ontario
obviously and I lived there for most of
my life and then I moved to st.
Catherine's with my now ex-girlfriend
and now I live on my own but when I was
when I moved to st. Catherine's I was
studying accounting and I went what
about even before then so you moved it
okay you did you move that you you moved
to st. Catherine's to study accounting
well you know I know okay I went to
Brock University in st. Catharines and I
was actually living with my mom for many
years and I lived there while I was
studying accounting and I graduated that
then moved to st. Catherine's that was
the time line and I got my master of
accountancy degree and that took five
and a half years let's let's figure out
what is it what contributes to someone
wanting to be an accountant um my my dad
has been in business his whole life and
now he actually teaches business which
is a lot more less stressful apparently
but yeah my dad was always in business
so I decided you know what you can you
know basically I want to do something in
business I remember my accounting
teacher in high school saying to me well
Matt you know I know you don't know what
you want to do but if you want to make
money go into accounting cuz you're
guaranteed to make a lot of money I
thought okay well I'm in high school I
don't know anything so that sounds good
you hear a lot of my dad does it
yeah well plus my dad's in business so I
just kind of kind of fits so I went into
that um what does your mom do cuz you
could have done that uh my mom jeez I
don't even my mom works at like an
employment thing so when people for
immigrants so when immigrants come in
she helps them get jobs and just helps
everybody get jobs type thing she works
for the government basically okay um
but yeah so yeah and I'll just tell the
story if you want any more details just
jump in let me know but yeah so I got my
master of accountancy degree and when I
graduated I worked in accounting for
about two years now immediately upon
graduating I are just before actually I
had really discovered all these people
that were making videos on YouTube
raywilliamjohnson was the first person I
discovered this was 2010 or actually
late 2009 I discovered him and then I
discovered dan brown pogobat philip
defranco wheezy waiter
Tessa Mickey Kitty Julian Smith just all
these people that were pretty talented
now you are you had graduated you had an
accounting degree I grab at this point
at this point at the end of 2009 I'd
graduated with my undergrad and then
between 2009 and 2010 I was working on
my master's degree there's only one more
year and that so you started working on
your masters and started watching
YouTube videos well yeah you can do both
of the same time you yeah sure you can
and when I started watching these people
you know it was so entertaining and I
realized my god these people are famous
like they're basically internet famous
and especially with Ray he was doing it
out of what looked like his apartment
and I was just fascinated that this is a
whole new world that we live in that
these people can start this type of
stuff with just a web what looked like
just a webcam and I was just fascinated
by so I thought to myself but after
about six months of watching these
people I thought I could probably do
that now that takes a certain kind of
person though well it does yeah because
the the average person I I think that's
changing you know I know that I think
kids especially who are watching
youtubers now it's kind of built in that
oh this can be a career because I know
there's people who do this as a career
right but it takes a certain kind of
person as an adult with a degree to be
watching YouTube content and then make
the connection to oh I could be doing
this so I mean were you just were you a
guy that liked to perform for people no
like any kind of background well it's
kind of weird that I went into
accounting because my whole life I've
been a kind of a goofy guy I always
enjoyed making people laugh I've always
enjoyed facts and things like that but I
never like when I started YouTube I
never thought you know oh this is gonna
be a career I just thought I'm just
gonna do this and this will always be
something that'll be my creative outlet
because when you're an accountant like I
mean if you're crunch often yeah you
need something or else you're gonna you
know lose it so that's just what I did I
started doing that working basically
9:00 to 5:00 Monday to Friday doing
videos on Saturdays writing the video
through the week at night so it's kind
of a hustle what was your living
situation of the time because you said
you moved to st. Catherine's yeah so I
moved here to st. Catherine's with my
girlfriend upon moving in with her
ex-girlfriend upon moving in with her I
you moved in with your ex-girlfriend no
well a girlfriend at the time okay that
would have been weird no but I moved in
with her and then I just I just was like
okay now I'm going to start making
videos I'm in a new place fresh start
let's just start making videos so I went
out I got a crappy handycam Sony
Handycam I mean it was 1080p that's all
I cared about I didn't know anything
about video editing I didn't know
anything about um you know white
balancing so my video my first set of
videos were very orange looking no
lighting no mic or anything but I just
jumped into it and everything I learned
I was completely self-taught off youtube
and I just had a really big imagination
so I what I would do is come up with
what I wanted to do in the video and
then figure it out after I never thought
like oh no could I do that I never
thought of that I just shot what I
wanted to do and then figured out how to
do it through you YouTube tutorials I've
never taken a class on video editing
nothing like that never learned how to
shoot you know professionally or
anything like that just learned
everything myself so and creatively you
I mean looking back at your earliest
videos very different than what you're
doing now yes I can see you know when
you list your influences you can you can
definitely see that at the beginning you
were kind of emulating you got a little
bit of a you got a little bit of fill
talking about maybe a current event here
there maybe you got a wheezywaiter clone
yeah I mean yet you get good I like this
it's you know you definitely see hey
they're doing this I'm just gonna throw
it all against the wall and then see
what sticks Yeah right that's kind of
basically yeah and I mean if you look at
my earliest videos I've always done
lists I've always done that they just
weren't top 10s I've done you know
everything from you know 10 ways 10 ways
to lose your man card which is just a
ridiculous video but I was one of my
first videos and that was inspired by
something I heard on the radio side disc
jockey we was talking about a man card
and I thought it was a hilarious topic
so I just came up with 10 things how to
be a manly man which is ironic because I
am the farthest thing from everything on
that list like I'm not like a manly man
at all I know you're not a card carrier
actually I am because the guy that owned
like I
it's like man card calm or official man
card calm they found the video and it
contacted me and said we love this we
what's your address we want to send you
an official man card so I got yeah so I
got that look like it's just a black man
card with my name and it says members
since and then it has my date of birth
and then till death yeah that's what it
says I'm seeing with a certificate and
everything so you got a man karma by
knowing somebody that's I well we all
have hey as long as you got we all have
our man card until we lose it that's the
way the man card but I don't really
believe that stuff just that's just the
technical how it works
but yeah so and that's about it so I
started doing skits no no you listen
we get into you know that's this
transition from those early videos so to
what you're doing now wait describe st.
Catharines because that's is that where
you're at now that's where I'm at now
yeah okay about a hundred and fifty
thousand people not a very big town I'm
not too small though not too small I
mean well and where I grew up which is
15 minutes away from that is only 50,000
so I moving on up but if you look at
like Buffalo New York Niagara Falls is
about 30 minutes above that st.
Catharines is about 30 minutes above
that Toronto is about an hour and a half
above that just to put it into
perspective so that's that's where I
live okay and it's in and if you're
doing accounting mm-hmm which I which
you're at a desk right this is this is
there's not a lot of movement going on
no if you're entering in your lifestyle
situation into like one of those fitness
apps you put sedentary base if you're an
accountant yeah so it might it's one
thing to be like okay well on the
weekends I'm going to what kind of
things did you hunt moose that's a
little thing I'm sorry there's different
things that you could do but you were
like I'm gonna do this other thing which
it's is a little you know this less
sedentary than accounting but it wasn't
like okay I'm gonna go and do this other
thing to bring myself some satisfaction
well what what
what was the initial allure of that were
you like that just seems more fun like
those people seem like they're having
more fun or those people seem like they
are reaching more people um I don't know
it's just it's it's hard to explain I
mean I like I just jumped into it
because it looked like something that I
I don't know I can't really explain it
to you to be completely honest it was
just something that I've always enjoyed
entertaining people I was always a
goofball in high school and grade school
so I thought to myself this is a way to
continue doing that just to the people
that watch me on YouTube so instead of
high school or grade school you know now
that I'm an adult well this is my only
other way to do it
so right that's just it was just my
creative outlet it's really all it was
and so yeah just continued from there
and it was something that just happened
as an outlet you know on the weekend I
imagine you sitting at your accounting
desk I mean we had engineering jobs rep
more than me would sit at his
engineering cubicle and obsess about all
the things that he wanted to be
interested in besides what he was only
paid to do yeah so I imagine you think
about like this is what's going into my
video this Saturday oh yeah Oh totally
it was really the only way to keep me
sane you know that's the only thing that
kept me sane and the only thing that
kept me awake was a lot of energy drinks
and coffee just a terribly unhealthy
unhealthy job and you're sitting there
all day and I'm so glad I'm doing what I
do so much better
so as you split your time between
accounting and YouTube there there was
no room for that girlfriend she had to
hit the road no no no no no nothing like
that
her name's Marcy she was the most so
isn't is one of the best people I've
ever known it just it just didn't work
out we we after a while we've been
together for we were together for five
years just kind of after a while seemed
like we were just really really good
friends you know it just kind of happens
there was no juicy story nothing ever
nothing happened no one did anything
we're still really good friends she's
still very supportive we have caught
coffee once in a while so everything's
good on me through a straw she doesn't
drink through a straw
picture that's great that's who one cup
of coffee two straws yeah you were
dating yeah I know something like that
but no no it's a couple months ago and
well okay fresh
this is woke a John Deere biscuits yeah
it's a June so July August yeah bout two
two and a half two months ago two and a
half months ago and Wow this is a five
year relationship yeah two months ago
yeah you move out she move out
I moved out because I moved in with her
originally was still her apartment so I
moved out and but it was you know it was
really tough but it was it was something
that I knew was the best thing for the
both of us you know and it was super
tough because she was one of the most
supportive people and like I said one of
the best people still is one of the best
people I've ever known in my life but
it's just sometimes you just don't click
and a half chemistry and it just didn't
work so it was just time to move on hmm
so to go back from those first videos
start to walk us through the transition
from emulating the youtubers that you
watched to moot you said you were doing
some list based things pretty early on
we can see that but I you know in
looking back through the channel I think
there's certain milestones that I can
you can count I can kind of trace an
evolution to arrive at what what you
have today in your mind how did that
happen and you know leading up to a
point where you could do this full-time
I'm curious how recent that's been um I
it's kind of it's tough i okay
so right up until the end of should I
think of the timeline now so it 2014
2013 so right up until the end of 2013 I
was about October ish I still only had
about 15,000 subscribers and though
working full-time
uh no so that's part of the story - I
was actually laid off
that's what so I'll do a little
backstory so what actually happened was
I was working in accounting for two
years and I was working for a small firm
what happens the risk of working at a
small firm is there much more if the
economy goes bad or anything happens
there
more you know something likely for to do
layoffs type thing and that was the
moment where a light bulb went off
because I remember the day I got laid
off I came home and I wasn't upset and I
actually I remember looking at Marcy and
smiling and saying I got laid off and it
was a it was like it was like this seed
of doubt this voice that was in the back
of my head for these two years you know
really came to the forefront and said
hey I've been telling you this whole
time you weren't happy you know
let's make a change and it was that
moment where I realized you know we live
in a world now where the the quote
unquote safe fruit is not that safe we
were always told to go to university get
a good job work the nine-to-five do that
for 40 years and then you die raise a
family and that raised the family first
not from as a corpse it generally
doesn't work out and people into that so
you know raise a family and then you die
but that doesn't that's not the world
anymore
and people are waking up to that fact
and I'm just glad that I woke up to that
at a relatively young age because I'm 29
right now I woke up to that at the age
of 27 and I think it took me as long as
it did because era I didn't realize it
longer because you know you spend five
and a half years in school you know you
can't it's it's hard to say jeez well I
changed my mind you know it's really I
think this is you know what I really
want to do and it it takes not many
people do that because if specially when
you already have a job I mean who's
gonna leave a nine-to-five job where you
have pay to to follow you know a wild
goose chase I mean making it on YouTube
is like winning the lottery it really is
it's very very difficult and I was
blessed enough that that happened to me
but you were at that point yeah one year
ago now basically it's almost October
yeah so one year ago you laid off yeah
and you got that small interface because
you knew I can go all-in with YouTube I
was laid off a year before that actually
so yeah so uh well what happened was
October ish was the almost one year
anniversary of getting laid off okay so
that whole time I was broke I had no
money
you know I'm that's one of the reasons
I'm so thankful to Marcy cuz she
really helped out during that time and
you know I was getting some unemployment
and stuff so that kind of health but
really I was hurting bad luckily I had a
bit of a savings or I'd been a really
bad shape but so you know on the year
anniversary when my unemployment
insurance ran out I had literally no
money I just but that whole time I never
stopped doing youtube because I thought
to myself and and I started doing other
things I started shooting some weddings
to make ends meet I started doing we've
all been there
yeah you do what you have to do you use
the skills you've you've done I've
gotten over the last three years on
YouTube to start going in different
directions and I thought to start
thinking myself okay maybe no I didn't
enjoy wedding video right-minded I know
you're one of the lucky ones it wasn't I
mean you know it's a if have you guys
done that it's a long day it's a really
we did yes we did it's a very big one it
felt like more though yeah it felt like
more weddings than well I only shot one
full day wedding so that's probably
similar to you guys but I did a lot of
like just the ceremony you know a few
hundred five hundred bucks like just you
know it's hard to live off of that yeah
and you know but I never gave up hope I
just kept doing YouTube and I thought to
myself if I just throw my tentacles out
there and touch on a little bit of
everything maybe something will take off
and it just so happened that in October
I think it was October anyways I took a
two-week trip across America do you guys
remember the Ford Fiesta movement
yeah where they gave away a bunch of
cars into a bunch of youtubers well my
friend Scott in Buffalo took myself and
my friend Rob Dyke across America to
visit our friend Dylan whose channels
householdhacker in Portland Oregon right
yeah so we went down to Buffalo picked
up Robyn Massachusetts came all the way
back to Buffalo when all the way to
Portland and came all the way back to
Buffalo and then I went home and then he
dropped Rob off in Massachusetts because
I didn't I couldn't handle being in a
car for another even eight hours after
two weeks but that trip really did a lot
for me because I did a lot of networking
in Portland I you know I signed to the
collective which is Dylan started the
sub Network called tube unity he
convinced me to sign with them and
that's really when everything took off I
started meeting people just now
working more and then all of the sudden
something happened where it just kind of
happens I don't know if that happened to
you guys I know you guys have gone viral
several times I mean your videos are
speak for themselves but for me I've
never gone viral
so my growth was very sudden because
right up until December I had about
30,000 subscribers and it took about six
months to reach well eight months now to
reach 2.5 million so that it all
happened very quickly and there was
about a three month period there where I
was getting 25,000 subscribers a day
which and I was right behind PewDiePie
in terms of growth there were some days
where I even beat him absolutely nuts it
is what was the first time that you
recognized that that was happening
because you're saying it wasn't one
viral video it was a it was a surge in
the channel now how long did a decision
to only do list videos precede that wave
of subscribers uh so what happened was I
didn't truth be told I didn't want to be
known as the list guy I always
considered myself very creative I didn't
want to give up my you know skit roots
the whole skit thing that I was doing so
I would do a skit one week and then I
would do a top ten list the other week
why I started doing top ten lists I
don't know I've just always liked the
I've experimented a lot I've tried top
twenty I've tried top 40 top fifty five
seven I've tried all kinds of numbers
and just through experimentation I
realized that people really liked top
tens there's just something about that
round number people like because you
would see in the performance of those
that's right that they would you know
you'd get it it was all in the analytics
it would start breaking a million views
at some point well I wasn't getting that
at first um it's funny before all this
happened I was happy to get 2,000 views
a week I thought that was a lot cuz it
is K I mean it's all relative light like
if you think about that that's 2,000
people that watched your video so now
that I get a million in like five days
it's just it still blows my mind cuz in
many ways I'm still that same guy in my
head but yeah I would do a skit one week
and then the next week I would do a top
ten and then I would do a skit and then
the top ten and back and forth and and I
we ended the video you would say
you know you would call people to
subscribe to push that big red button
and you'd say subscribe to see my other
comedy videos and I remember seeing that
and I was like well are they list videos
are like videos so there was this trying
to figure out and I think that that was
my assumption was there's an identity
crisis going on here the fans want those
lists yeah but he wants to be a comedian
it was it was an evolution it was a
transition I that was where it was
happening where you know I started
looking at the analytics and thinking oh
my god I'm getting 50,000 views on the
skits but my lists are getting 200,000
yes so what would happen and I would
notice that there was a huge jump at
subscribers when I do the top tens
just boom happens so I was thinking
myself what would happen if I
exclusively did top tens and the rest is
history that's really that's really what
it that's really what happened but it
wasn't an easy decision it was not if
you look at my outro screen I stopped
using the word comedy and I stopped like
if you up until a certain point I would
say subscribe new comedy videos every
Saturday right and I left that in there
for a while even after I started doing
exclusively top 10s but after a while I
started realizing and I started and I
even started taking them out of the
category of comedy because up until then
they had all been considered comedy and
I the reason I left it as that is
because I always was doing a little like
you guys have probably you know you've
seen it I do a little bit of comedy in
between the facts try to keep it light
kind of like a bill and I was a big
inspiration for me that way
it was interesting the infotainment type
stuff yeah so I was I would that's kind
of what happened I realized you know
what
this is more education at this point the
comedy is secondary so I took the word
comedy out of my endcard where I call
people to action to subscribe and and I
started moving it to the classifying
them as education in the education
category and that actually I think hurt
my subscribership actually because as
soon as I did that I started going from
25,000 a day down to I'm about at 6 I
average 6 to 8 thousand a day now which
is still nothing to sneeze at but that's
a big drop and I think that I think
part of it was because of the switch
from comedy to entertainment or - sorry
education because I think a lot of
people look at look for more comedy
videos than they do education videos but
education is pretty big on YouTube now
so it's I'm still getting a decent
amount of well you know this is so
fascinating I mean we're so fascinated
with this obviously because we have an
interest in understanding this platform
but I think it's so cool to talk to you
right now because you are in the middle
of this right I mean you've gained a
million-and-a-half subscribe subscribers
since May hmm yep crazy right in know
viral video that's why I'm proud of that
cuz it's like I stopped well I think a
lot of people would consider multiple
million views viral but yeah yeah not
viral in the turn of the ways you guys
10 millions or whatever yeah but it's
just so fascinating because you started
with a certain thing and you know one of
my favorite videos of yours is you're a
million subscriber thank you video where
you show your first oh really that you
you put up because I think it helps to
kind of encapsulate the process so much
you've got this video that you you say
this is gonna be embarrassing for me to
show you know you and she said you were
you were definitely preparing the
audience for how embarrassed he was
gonna be by showing this video and then
it's a totally different style like we
said it was very easy to see the
different things that you have pulled
from to put this video together the the
different people that you've been
influenced by and now to see how so much
has you've honed in on this very
specific style that is working and so
there's this dynamic of like well I kind
of wanted to do this but the audience
has dictated that I'm doing this and
it's addictive is it not it's very
addictive it's very true especially
especially when you it's something
you've wanted for three-and-a-half years
yeah and for it to finally happen I mean
for anyone out there that
hasn't experienced anything like this it
is it's almost like a drug like you get
like a high off of it like you start
seeing all these people like ten
thousand subscribers a day it's like oh
my god like you get excited it's like
that's a lot of people like I'm growing
so quickly and you get hooked on it so
you want to do more top 10s and more of
what you're doing to keep those people
coming and it just keeps growing and
growing and it gets it's it's it's like
a drug addiction I don't want to say
that what it is it's like it's like I
don't want to call it Fame I don't like
using that word but it's like the
notoriety the attention it's it's
addictive it really is well and I think
I mean for the way I relate to it I mean
obviously it's cool to be recognized for
doing something but when you just think
about you think about the longevity you
know you want to be in this business for
a long time and you were the success not
just to be able to say that I'm
successful but to be able to keep doing
it it's it's so you you gravitate
towards the things that you're like well
I mean I kind of liked those sketches
but boy they don't want they don't want
that from me yeah so why am I gonna give
them something they don't want when I
can just I can kind of systematically
give them exactly what they're asking
for yeah exactly
and and I mean it's sort of uh it's it's
a trade-off because when you when I used
to do sketches and I mean I still enjoy
that because you're not boxed into a top
ten format I can do anything I want I
can move the camera I can shoot clones I
can do all that stuff but you know when
you upload a video like that and I
remember getting you know say 2000 views
on it but then I do it top ten I get far
more it really I don't know the the top
tens outweigh the loss of not being able
to have that creativity because you're
getting so much more attention it's just
it satisfies you in a different way you
know what I'm saying so yeah I can't be
as creative but I mean you guys have
probably seen some of my more recent
videos I try to still use that
creativity like I'll appear right at the
beginning like out of nowhere you know
what I'm saying or like I don't know
like I'll crash-land through the roof
like I did in my most recent video so I
elements of that are still there it's
not dead it's just I'm I'm picking and
choosing my
how to use my creativity now mm-hmm is
there a fear that either you're still
gonna get tired of it I mean that for
certain people doing anything any one
thing for too long can feel like uh
being an accountant at a desk or is
there a fear that the audience is gonna
change their mind you do anything any
one thing too long they lose interest um
there isn't a fear it's how do I explain
it it's more of you know I think that
people universally just like facts they
like to learn things and they like to do
it in a fun way
um do I think that you know this could
all go away someday sure I do I think
YouTube could you all go away someday
not just the the the popularity of lists
so um I don't ever think about the
future
I really don't it's that's something
that I've learned in the last year is
live in the present because there's so
much happening in my life like right now
I mean this I'm here for LA for a week
it would be a terrible thing to think at
any point during this week oh jeez I
wonder you know if I'm gonna lose views
next week or subscribers it's like May
and live in the moment I'm here now I'm
I'm you know on ear biscuits like this
is a cool opportunity I get to see you
guys again like it live for the now man
like that's the thing that I tell people
all the time it's don't worry don't live
in the past what's in the past in the
past don't think about the future
because all we have is right now and you
know that's something that I truly and
take risks that's the most important
thing is that a is that a discipline
you've required or do you think that is
a personality makeup that you have that
it's a gift that comes along oh no
that's something I've learned okay I
believe it or not up until recently I
was a extremely conservative person I
taking a trip to LA by myself forget
about it a year ago even six months ago
but them every single time I realized
that every single time I've ever stepped
out of my comfort zone something amazing
has happened from it every single time
and to anyone listening honestly that
would be my one thing I want you to take
away from any of this advice I'm giving
is step out of your comfort zone and
truly
do something that scares you do
something that sounds amazing but you
know is absolutely terrifying for you
and you will one of two things will
happen if it's if it's YouTube some
incredible opportunity could come out of
it or if nothing else you'll just grow
as a person and that's really important
to grow as a person you don't want to
stay stagnant and do the same things
over and over cuz that's that's a boring
life man do something exciting you know
what I mean so that's I don't know
that's my PSA I want to talk about the
specifics of you know how the content
has arrived at what it is right now you
know there's there's a couple of things
I mean it's not as simple as okay well I
was doing some sketches and and now I'm
just doing the list videos but the tone
how I would describe the guy who is
delivering the information in your most
recent video versus your first video
right so in the first video it was like
okay I'm a funny guy I'm a comedian and
I'm gonna do and say some things that
are funny and this is all for your
entertainment this is all to make you
laugh now it's very much this is very
much about you actually getting what I'm
saying almost to the point that your
your tone your enunciation you are you
are speaking to the audience as if it is
very important that they understand
almost as if you're taking into account
that there are people out there who are
ESL you know the English is a second
language you are clarifying things very
almost to the point where you're like
okay if I'm if I'm in a American guy
your age I would be like I almost feel
like you're you're speaking you're not
speaking to me do you know what I mean
yeah I've actually gotten many messages
from people that are ESL that have said
you know my second language is English
but I'm I'm I speak Spanish so I speak
French and that your videos are teaching
me how to speak English believe it or
not they'll say things like I totally
believe your pronunciation is excellent
and for the record I don't actually
speak that properly all the time but
doing these videos has really taught me
to speak properly because we all kind of
use slang and say like hey what's up or
something like that right
like I just said something like that
like I don't that's how I speak like
everyone speaks with how did you come to
that decision huh did you get did you
buy videos back so I'd watch the videos
back and be like oh what did I say there
you know what I mean like and as a
viewer I don't think they're gonna
understand if I said this word or this
word so I started really being careful
and it happens all the time and I like
you know people don't realize how long
it takes to make these videos not just
because the research but I do often you
know 20 takes on one sentence because I
can't get that T out properly and it's
minute matters I can't think of any
specific example but just that type of
stuff and it's frustrating but you know
I find myself it's it's now carrying
over to real life where I'll be talking
in a conversation and I will purposely
catch myself before I even say the word
in pronoun pronunciate it really
correctly uh so yeah it's it's funny how
to go back to what you were saying about
my original videos to now it's you sort
of and tell me if you guys agree with
this you sort of find your on-camera
persona your presence you know when you
first start you're kind of you don't
know what you look like like now when I
make a face I know exactly what it looks
like to the other person while I'm
making it because I've done it I've seen
my face a hundred million different ways
right um especially the teeth right I'm
just like I know exactly what that looks
like Oh without a doubt I mean you know
I would say we're very much ourselves on
good mythical morning but anyone who
listens to ear biscuits will know that
the the the tone of what you're gonna
get on the air biscuit and what you're
gonna get on good mythical morning are
they're they're distinct you know and
there's a different energy there's a
different yeah same person but you know
it's a different package yeah I
definitely relate to that and you get
that I mean I
we've lost the majority of our southern
accent because of watching ourselves
back for years upon years not video and
it's not necessarily I don't think it's
it's not being ashamed of the southern
accent but it's a I don't know how
that's coming across to the masses right
so if I want to speak to everyone it's
so definitely relate to that mm-hmm and
they say that you know do you guys hear
an accent the way I speak because I'm
Canadian you
I hear that do you I mean on a number of
words but yeah not you know put explain
like what I'm curious to hear this
because I hear America say that all the
time baby Oh UT Oh God it's mostly about
yeah see I see you're trying you're
trying I try but if I say it quickly
like about it's it's a rounded out like
it's not it's not a boot like people
exaggerate boot it's not a boot it's
about it's like it's oh you it's like
rounded it's strange it I don't know why
we do that but I would say that I mean
my advice to all three of us would be
let's just kind of keep it where it is
right now it's like it's it's been you
know it's it's the edges have been taken
off of it but we don't want to go any
further you should you should still I
should be able to tell that you're
Canadian by hearing you talk I think
that that's an asset yeah I think I
think it is I mean some people I mean
look at a British youtuber any one of
them really they're super popular why
well because you know Charlie McDonnell
for example it makes great content but
people love that accent
it's a it's a rare import type thing you
know I'm saying like they're they watch
it and it's like all that I like that
novel it's another thing that you've
done is you you're clean you know your
your initial content had never used to
be had some off-color stuff tell us
about that evolution um I I so I never
really swore heavily there's one video
that I say everything and a lot of it
and that was just an experimental video
to see how it would work and I got a lot
of feedback from that video saying like
especially from like my family and stuff
they did say things like all geez like
we didn't really like that and I was
kind of embarrassed by it so I didn't do
that ever again
but yeah my original videos I would only
say the S word I'd never said the F word
if I did i bleeped it and it was
intentional I would write it into the
script for comedy yeah but now cuz I
don't really speak like that but in in
now I purposely leave that out because I
know I have a very young audience so I
mean I have an audience of all different
ages but really probably from like 8 to
16 8 to 20 so it's still fairly young I
get a lot of letters on my second
channel where I do my mail with Matt
series a lot of eight-year-old
ten year olds twelve year old so not
just the fact that I know they're
watching but I also get a lot of
messages from parents I get a lot of
parents messaging me on my Facebook page
saying hey I just wanted to say thank
you for your clean content I love my son
watching your videos cuz he learns
things and that's cool like you know
like I wake up pretty much every morning
I have my coffee through a straw and I
sit there and I and I have my cereal or
whatever I'm eating and I answer my
facebook messages that's kind of a
tradition that I have every day in my
tweets and stuff and a lot of them are
from parents a lot so that's kind of I
kind of think to myself like I have
almost an obligation at this point you
know like 2.5 million people that's a
lot of people it's the same thing with
you guys what do you add three point
five three point something good mythical
morning yeah that's a lot of people like
think about that that's that's almost
double the size of like Toronto right so
you got a figure you know you have
probably a lot of people that wake up
that expect a certain quality of content
certain amount of cleanliness and if you
go out there and start dropping f-bombs
it's an off-brand thing you know it's a
branding thing really is what it is so
that's I just try to keep it clean yeah
do you see YouTube as a game
Rhett and I refer to playing a YouTube
game as that way of characterizing the
techniques to build a channel do you see
it as a game no I don't you know what I
don't not not in a trivialization kind
of a way you know I know you're saying
in like a strategic everything is a
decision what's the thumbnail what am I
in the thumbnail am I in every thumbnail
what's the title is the number-10 well
that stuff matters that once a week and
you have to be cognizant of that and you
definitely have to pay attention to that
but I still I'm actually really glad
that my growth happens so rapidly so
quickly because in many ways I'm still
and I'm also glad that I struggled for
so long because in many ways to this day
I'm still that guy I still remember
having 10,000 subscribers and thinking
man I would love to be famous because
like like it's cool to have that many
people I still don't look at myself as
famous I you know I don't really like
that word but now I definitely have
notoriety now but it's cool
yeah I don't know I I don't look at as a
game I look at it as okay I know what I
have to do I know I have to put myself
in the thumbnail with a with a goofy
face with the smile and the teeth people
expect that they look for that every
Saturday morning I know that I have to
put a 10 in the title I know that I have
to use catchy title like blah blah blah
you didn't know or blah blah blah of all
time or you etc you guys know how that
stuff works very BuzzFeed II type styles
of words and but I but I don't look at
it as what can I do to get the most
views I don't look at it like that I use
a certain standard and that's it because
I don't like to I never look at my
analytics I never look at there was a
while there when I was getting the
25,000 a day where I was looking at man
likes every day is getting excited about
oh my god a quarter of a hundred
thousand people it's amazing but I don't
do that anymore because you can really
get obsessed with that stuff and you can
really like I said it's almost like a
drug like you start looking for it and
it's like oh like I wonder how many I'm
gonna get today it's like you're
feigning for those subscribers yeah I
know this might sound silly to people
listening but until you actually
experience it it's a bizarre thing
mm-hmm and I don't do that anymore
I just I'm sort of returning almost to
my roots of I'm just a guy that likes
making videos I just want to continue
doing that and I'm just gonna make
topics that I find interesting I've
never done I think there have only been
one or two occasions where I've done a
topic that I really wasn't interested in
but was so highly requested that I had
to do it but every other video is sort
I'm not into zombies much this is
actually pre top-10 I think trying to
think now I know it wasn't it was top
ten it was called ten ways to survive
the zombie apocalypse and I'm not a
zombie guy I'm really not I've never
gotten into Walking Dead I think it's a
decent show but I've never really got
into that whole genre so that's an
example of one you wouldn't do now I
know I probably would because again it
was so highly requested that it was just
something like I can't ignore this
anymore
but 99% of my videos or things that
topics that I would find interesting and
that's always how I've done my videos is
a topic that
I only make videos and put out videos
that I would like to see and I've always
run my channel that way I've never done
a video and I've never put anything in a
video that I haven't been proud of or
have thought to myself you know oh I
don't know about that I've never done
that it's always been that's cool
I gave 100% at that and I think I think
my content shows that even even as
almost amateur as my original videos
were there's still a level of quality
there and I pride myself on that and
I've yeah I've never uploaded a vlog on
my main channel I mean I I suppose I
have one or two but nothing nothing
consistent like that well I think it's
interesting you're touching on something
which is the balance between leading
your audience and being led by your
audience right having the audience
dictate what you're gonna do and then
sort of dictating that for your audience
which any youtuber I one of the the
dynamics of YouTube is we are on the the
opposite end of the spectrum from say
the Coen brothers you know in the corn
brothers sit down or Wes Anderson sits
down it to conceptualize a film my
impression is they could care less or
they couldn't care less about what
people want right it's very much about
what they want to create we don't have
that luxury in one sense we have to
think because it the audience is so
involved in the audience is so
responsive and they're so vocal I think
it's a beautiful thing about YouTube it
sounds to me one of the things I hear
you saying because you're you're we've
talked about this this this evolution of
your content which is very much
responding to the audience letting the
audience kind of determine what you were
going to make but you have a strong
desire to hold on to okay I'm not gonna
talk about things that I'm not
interested in you know it may be one
percent of the time but describe that
balance of listening and being led by
the audience and then leading the
audience and coming up with what you're
gonna do next uh it's it's tough I mean
um I kind of take the heavy Apple
approach you know people don't know what
they want you just have to give them
what they want yeah make them understand
what they want to teach them what they
would that type of thing
yeah it's pompous as that sounds but I
think people for the most part just on
what they don't know they want yeah you
know what I mean like don't don't follow
what everybody else is doing is as
ironic as that is because there's a lot
of people doing list videos but I think
you know not to go off on a tangent but
I think that's what separates us from a
lot of these other faceless top-10
channels or list channels and I don't
want to name names but I know the people
behind almost all of them actually I'll
just say all-time tens you guys are
probably familiar with them I know the
entire team behind all-time tens amazing
videos but what I think my in great guys
but I think what my advantage over them
in any other list channel except you
guys because you use your faces is I use
my face and people like to be spoken to
by a person and a channel like
alltime10s is fantastic and I love those
guys but it's just text on a screen with
pictures and there's something be said
for having a personality and speaking to
somebody because it's it's like being in
school you know and when you're in
school you have that really awesome
teacher everybody's always had that one
teacher just you remember forever
because it you learn so much and they
made learning fun that's what I aim to
do and I think that's what we kind of
all do here is is we you know you guys
do it on good mythical morning and you
guys have a lot of fun while you're
doing it in the audience picks up on
that and it almost takes down the
barrier for learning because when you're
in school people that's why many people
hate school and they they look forward
to snow days and crap like that because
you know they know they're gonna come in
they're just gonna hear a lecture and
it's gonna be boring but if the I had
this one teacher that always told a joke
at the beginning of class it's just
loosened you up you know what I mean put
the wall down so I think that's what
sets it apart us apart and I totally
forgot what you asked originally now cuz
I totally went off in a tangent well
just 9ss why don't you like danger dolan
and I think that's what Oh God
you know it's funny I just recently
learned is that a serious question no I
was didn't want to mention names no I
there he's faceless yeah I just recently
learned who that guy was and the funny
thing is you know how I found out who he
was was because I did a video called the
ten inventors that were killed by their
own invention yeah yeah and apparently
that was like his first
and I was unaware he even existed and it
was also the first thing we talked about
right but Niagara Falls yeah yep and he
came all so many people see a lot of the
people that subscribe to you subscribe
to me subscribe to all time 10s
subscribe to danger dolan and you know
they people claim ripoff all the time i
don't know if you guys get it yeah but i
get it all the time and it's like man
first and foremost first and foremost
everything is a remix you guys know what
I'm saying laughs there are no original
ideas anymore everything that could have
been done has been done by now
and there's actually a awesome
documentary three-part documentary
that's free to watch online called
everything is a remix have you guys seen
it
I know about it yeah you should watch it
it's really really good it's fascinating
anyways definitely check that out
but um yeah I got a whole bunch of
comments uh oh man you know you've lost
your own ideas now you're ripping this
person off you're ripping all the time
tens off and it's like there are
multiple ways to do the same topic and I
you know I never and that's when I
really sit for a while there I was
searching a topic before I did it and I
can't tell you how many topics I threw
in the trash because they were already
done and after a while I realized you
know what I'm not searching on YouTube
anymore because it's probably been done
so I'm just going to do it and if people
claim ripoff that's cool because I'm
still you know there's that's just gonna
be 300 dislikes out of 50,000 likes I'm
okay with that so there's there's
multiple ways to do the same topic and
just make it your own you know what I
mean yeah and that's another piece of
advice I did tell anyone listening who
wants to make youtube videos is don't
search if something's been done already
never ever do that if you want to do
something like a morning talk show with
your best friend and you know you want
to you know have a rooster shooting fire
out of it smells you know who knows if
that's been done before I don't know but
but do it you know what I mean jump in
don't research that stuff because you
know it's probably been done and it'll
just stop you from doing it and when you
do it yourself you're gonna do it in
your own way and you're gonna do it with
your own personality in your own style
so just jump into it don't do the
morning thing that's been taken yeah but
you know what I'm saying it's just
everything's been done by now yeah I
mean yeah we ease but when you do
especially you know let's say do five
videos a week it's we'd run into that
problem quite a quite a bit and have to
kind of make a decision was like okay
well can you do can we do it differently
I'm trying to figure out if I agree with
that
piece of advice Matt I don't which part
the the searching before you do I I
agree with the sentiment that if you
really have in your heart or mind to
create something you should express
yourself what here's here's an example I
think the reason that we might be more
personally sensitive to this is because
our background is in more that you know
like original songs yeah and sketch
isn't that kind of thing yeah we have to
Google I'm a topic for a song before we
throw ever as much as we're gonna put
into time and because you can't if you
can't get out of that if you make I'm on
a boat and you didn't know there was I'm
on a boat you can't explain to anyone
that that's not like a subject in a top
ten list right that's a specific comedic
angle right I mean here's a great
example I don't know if you've ever told
this story but we we did a song last
year called yeah put the phone down no
let's get off this funky on the phone
get off the phone and we wrote the song
and it was called put the phone down we
had written the song if it's a branded
it was a branded project so we had
written the song it had been approved by
the brand and everything and it was like
you know what we always check this I
don't know why we did we didn't check
this one but let's just make sure that
this hasn't been done and we found a
video was it what's the guy's name
DJ he did the whole foods rap I can't
remember his name
we've met him a couple times he did the
whole foods rap and so it's getting real
in the whole fools pocket yeah so he's a
comedic musician and he did a song
called but the phone got the phone down
and it was it was a rap and it was he
had not only was it called put the phone
down which is what we were gonna call
our song he had some of the same exact
jokes in fact he had a coffee shop scene
in which he was waiting in line behind
someone who was on their phone we had
written a whole verse about in being in
line behind someone who was at a coffee
shop on a phone and there was like two
or three other things we're like how
this happen how can you come up with the
exact same title and the exact same
jokes that's Wells are because that's
just the way comedy work right
observational comedy especially so we
had to revisit the whole song we had to
change the lyrics we had to change what
we called it because from that
standpoint it was like okay well but I
feel I don't I disagree and I agree
because it in one sentence we're not
gonna not talk about the top ten
whatever it might be just because it's
been done because it will have been done
but we just want to check that okay well
maybe it wasn't done last week by a
competitive YouTube channel and let's
see if we can come with a slightly
slightly different treatment so a you
know I think there's just but you're
right if you're gonna keep yourself from
doing something that's been done well
you're not gonna do anything yeah I just
meant don't allow it don't let it be a
hindrance right to your Creator don't be
boxed in but for example for myself if I
googled I wonder if anyone's doing top
ten lists no I would have never been
Ryan David Letterman good point the good
point you know and it's the same thing
everybody's done top ten David Letterman
started that probably in some way
influenced all time tens you know I
didn't know who all time tens was
because I've been doing videos for four
years but then people started mentioning
them on my channel and then I started
talking to them and I I met the guys
behind the team and everything but yeah
it's like you know I would I wouldn't be
where I am if I started doing if I
didn't start doing top ten lists at all
can you know consistently so yeah it's
you know it's got to be a balance I
think so if you think about where you're
going from here what's next what is the
next year look like how do you set your
path as to how are you going to innovate
well I thought this was the pinnacle
right here isn't here this is like am I
not done is this is like yeah you can
quit now Oh perfect cool if you decide
not to quit now if I decide not to host
cheese old yeah cheese I don't know I
know you don't like to think about the
future but I'm challenging you to think
about the future yeah well I've been
thinking about starting a new series
that I really don't want to mention
right now because I looked it up and I
don't think it's been done
oh so it's in but it's exactly in line
with what I'm
and it makes a whole lot of sense and I
unfortunately can't talk about it here
but I'll tell you guys after okay but it
happened it will tell everybody yeah
that's cool but no big deal I guess and
then you guys might end up doing it at
this point right now we'll guess and a
few guys I'll tell you one of us will be
right oh yeah if you guess it no we
don't want to do that to you go ahead go
ahead shoot a couple oh oh I was gonna
say we guess it's exactly in line with
what I'm doing now it makes a lot of
sense okay I was gonna say a Spanish
version of what you know okay all right
we should do that I think it still is
still gonna be list based but it's going
it's not gonna be facts it's gonna be 3d
and now work with me here because he's
he's he's oradour and we're good at this
I think you're about to get worried
focus on me right now again all right
he's what he's gonna do is still list
base but it's instead of being about
facts I would if I were him I would go
in a direction that maybe is it has it
is advice no not advice you've done some
advice and it's not tips it's not to
know it's in the exact same vein of what
I'm doing now clips no it's more no I
think it's gonna be examples of
something that fit a category but not
facts so right now there see if to try
to read it it's almost it's all I see
now you're just fishing guys give us one
hit well you want people to be excited
about this right but you also you don't
want what I'm not gonna do it um and it
would because I know if I say this
someone will end up taking it and I
don't think it's been done yet I mean
but you're on record saying you've done
it and then you're gonna run back to III
I'm thinking about say well this is in
line with what you're saying about the
future to go back to that what I plan on
doing is just continuing what I'm doing
but potentially continuing to evolve in
any way that I see fit or that I think
is necessary for the continuation of my
channel but also to experiment a little
bit then start
something you know I just want to tell
you guys now I I really shouldn't
all right use constraint here's a better
idea here's an even better start your
camera sit down with a stack of mail and
spend the next hour and a half or more
making a continuous video of opening and
reading me do that that's what you don't
like a terrible terrible idea
this has been fun I'm gonna rescue from
yourself so you know thanks for helping
us make this here bisque it's great to
get to know you sign the table yeah we
do like on-air like right now yeah sign
it was not ten times can I be precise
jenna Marbles and there you have it our
conversation with Matt Santoro
fascinating you know all right you can't
boil it down to just ten points in the
list though you know you got a like a
try
you had it that's what a near biscuit is
but maybe I'm not how about 50 points I
could boil it down to 50 amazing facts
about what we just talked about but that
would that would be difficult to do
maybe he'll do that Matt please don't do
that you don't have to do that
it was fascinating to me for a number of
reasons I think it's you know he's one
of the only guys that we've talked to on
your biscuits who is in the midst of
this amazing upswing
a lot of people we've talked to have
kind of been through a few ups and downs
or whatever and that question of
balancing between striking a balance
between dictating the canta canta
dictating the content and being dictated
to by your audience you know being led
by your audience or leading your
audience is something that I can't help
but be introspective about because we're
doing a lot of the same things right
we've touched on to some of the same
subjects and good mythical morning taps
into the same mentality a lot of times
we do a lot of lists videos we do videos
that we feel like are tapping into what
people want to see right and it's in
it's it's so you know it's easy
when something's working it's easy to
keep doing it I appreciated his honest
response that you know when things start
working it's it perpetuates itself it's
easy to want to keep doing it now I
think that you know there there does get
to be a point when if you keep doing
list videos you know I maybe he'll get
to a point where he has to ask the
question well how many more of these do
I want to keep doing you know he's
already talking about iterating kind of
branching out into something different I
think that's smart I think he's I think
things to do that got to do that he's
also right that people are not gonna
quit wanting to learn and I don't think
that people are gonna quit wanting to
learn having things organized in a list
I mean this is an old system that's
really being implemented onto a new
platform but you look at someone like
ray william johnson on equals three
which he was heavily influenced by and
Ray just couldn't you know I haven't
talked to Ray about it I'd love to get
him on your biscuits but I have surmised
that Ray just he couldn't keep doing the
show he couldn't keep doing equals three
and setting up the clips and then
knocking them down you know he had to
move on to doing something else to move
into acting and things like that
so it wasn't the audience that dictated
that move it was certainly not it was
him and so I think it's when we talked
to Matt at this point it's still so
fresh that I think when you ask him that
question he's like yeah I'm this is you
know I just what I'm doing I'm not gonna
think too much about the future I what I
guess on my theory is I don't think it's
gonna be the audience that is going to
instigate a change in content I think
it's gonna be himself we can relate to
that right you just you you you evolve
you evolve as a creator well and for us
you know I think our preference is to to
not commit so fully to one format say
with good mythical morning that we're
actually afraid of being pigeon-holed
and you know I think that was behind
some of my questions was just my own
fear of well are we not going all-in
enough with the things that were
because we're not willing to be seen as
certain people who just make less videos
or eat extreme foods you know you can't
sustain that five days a week anyway but
right you know it taking more of a slow
growth model which things are still
working out for us but he may become it
you've got to give them what they don't
know they want I think we throw that
around a lot too and trying to figure
out you know how are we gonna iterate on
good mythical morning so it doesn't get
stale for the audience or for us yeah
and I think you know words of wisdom
from format that are very applicable to
anyone who is making YouTube content or
aspires to make YouTube content don't
get into the numbers chasing game even
though you may look at what he's done
and he's found something that's working
and he's getting millions of views him
saying that he's no longer focusing so
much on well how many subscribers are
not getting in a day and I'm not going
in and looking at the analytics because
it is something you can really obsess
about and I think it's can be really
unhealthy and we've been there we've
been there and it usually happens in the
midst of an incredible success is when
you really get into it and then it kind
of wanes a little bit and you start
panicking yeah I also was impressed that
he didn't seem to have a chip on his
shoulder about being a list video guy
you know maybe he's still in process but
I think that he's dealt with that and
you know he he owns it and he says you
know what I'm gonna make these list
videos and they're gonna people want
them and I'm gonna give them to him and
I'm gonna own that and even if someone
else has already done something I'm
gonna do it in my way and you know
everything is a remix okay you know how
much is kind of him preaching to himself
how much is him you know actually
believing those things I don't know I
think there's a good question as I
listen back to it well let Matt know how
much you appreciated him and his ear
biscuit you can do that on Twitter at
Matthew Santoro he is the at Matthew
Santoro account unless there's someone
who has somehow gotten verified and
looks exactly like it but I'm almost
sure that's him so let him know
hashtag ear biscuits let us know how
what you think about
your biscuit near biscuits in general
you can do that by leaving a comment on
iTunes a review a rating that's very
helpful to us you can also leave a
comment on soundcloud and we appreciate
you tasting this biscuit with us we'll
bake another one and speak at it next
week
[Music]
[Music]